I know this is a fantastic partisan and
it's one that was actually written
especially for you in cockneys vs.
zombies what's that like as an actor to
have a part made for you well it's an
honor isn't it it's an honor when I read
the script I thought this is fantastic
it could have been written for me then
when I met James he told me he did write
it with me in mind so it's a really
kick-ass part isn't it do you find that
as a more mature and more experienced
actor that you're not getting those kind
of roles that you'd like to see more of
them oh I'd love to you well I mean I
just want to be working anyway but I
mean let's be honest I'm getting a
little bit too old to be playing
gangsters nowadays so I've shifted me
into the grandfather role and I'm very
happy to be so you know very happy to be
doing it you get a lot of action in the
film don't you your offing zombies just
like the rest of the companies what's
your favorite kill my favorite kill is a
where I take a zombie's head off with a
set of alligator lovers fantastically
inventive kills in the film on their
every new zombie films and horror films
the kind of thing you like to watch when
you're at home not necessarily but I
should probably be watching more of them
nowadays yeah now you mentioned the
alligator officers you would you have a
weapon of choice if you of course in a
zombie apocalypse yeah I'd like the
rifle I've got in there so it's an m16
with a grenade launcher attached I do I
have one of those yeah do you think
you'd be good off in the zombies
be [ __ ] good I know you've got coming
up next another kind of Girish role
haven't you in the in the Sweeney at the
very British film tell us a little bit
about that yeah I play a mr. fear mr.
fixit's you know in a man in the shadows
I'm an old friend of the character that
ray plays and if you need false
documents if you need a pistol you need
to get rid of some gold I'm the man that
can fix it for you it's a nice character
to play it's very different isn't it to
the original TV series in the sense that
obviously we're in modern-day London
everything's very kind of high-tech it's
very swish the kind of offices and
everything they're in what do you think
about that take on the original series
well I mean this is it sells on the name
the Swaney people film but I mean
there's 40 years difference so you know
nobody had mobile phones Tony for
instance you know I mean London was this
built up the guy the directed Nick Love
has made a wonderful job of a shooting
London great job yeah it looks really
fantastic yeah when you started acting
you had a real small rodent you an
American Werewolf in London so how did
it compare being in there I mean I my
first my first science fiction film
first film I ever made was Fahrenheit
451
directed by Francois Truffaut so that
was a science fiction movie and I had a
small part in American World War Finland
a plane cab driver yeah
as you enjoy those roles is it nice to
have different kind of parts and
different childhood role right though I
don't have a problem I don't pick and
choose give me the job and I'll do it
and is important do you think Tazewell
to support young British film makers in
films like cockneys vs. zombies
absolutely yeah yeah and this young
director and this lovely young writer I
mean they know all the encouragement
they can get
you